how significant is it the fact that your
forces have retaken this airbag
uh i think it's very important for these
guys
for our soldiers
who deterred the aggressor and kicked
them out from the gastoma you know the
somalitis was a symbolic place that the
russian aggression was started here
they're trying to deploy here the
parachute troopers here and starting the
occupation on the capital of our country
and our army
kicks them out that's that's it and is
it correct that russian forces have left
the entire kiev region now
yes it's correct if we are talking about
the key region or kiev oblast we call it
in our language so it's it's correct
they kick them out and do you believe
they've kicked them out or are they
regrouped have they retreated or are
they regrouping to come back uh it
depends on your uh vocabulary what do
you think do you think they're going to
try again uh
it depends on the mind of the
chairman in the kremlin so we will see
it and how positive are you in terms of
what's going to happen next for in this
war
i think next will be our victory
i am positive
okay and and do you think that they're
going to though try to hit harder in the
south and the south and the east sure
it's uh it will continue but i think
that our
armed forces are ready to deter them and
after that also kick them out from our
country and what about the horrors that
have been left behind can you talk about
that the mass graves is that true are
you seeing evidence of civilians being
killed in bucca in airpin
yes i think it's
new cases for the gog
international criminal court and i think
that will be a lot of evidence and we
will see new
nureberg process uh probably in bucha
probably in european or in kharkiv or in
marijuana it will be a lot of new
nurburgs process against the criminal
military criminal
who did it in our country